نقلت شبكه سي ان ان الامريكيه عن مصدر
عسكري واوكراني ان القوات الخاصه
الاوكرانيه تقف وراء هجمات نوعيه بطائرات
مسيره ضد قوات الدعم السريع في العاصمه
السودانيه الخرطوم ولم تنفي استخبارات
الجيش الاوكراني او تؤكد ما جاء في
التحقيق الذي ورد فيه عن مسؤول سوداني ان
نحو 90% من اسلحه الدعم السريع مصدرها
فاجنر
[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم مشاهدينا الاعزاء كندا خبر
حلقتنا ولنا في نقاشه ثلاثه مسارات ما
حقيقه وحيفيات تنفيذ القوات الخاصه
الاوكرانيه هجمات داخل الاراضي السودانيه
استهدفت فيها قوه الدعم السريع المدعومه
من فاجنر
والى اي مدى تؤشر هذه الخطوه على اتساع
نطاق المواجهه بين روسيا واوكرانيا لتشمل
ساحات وجبهات جديده وهل حصلت كياب على
غطاء غربي لتنفيذ مثل هذه العمليات
كيف نقرا ردود الافعال على هذه الخطوه وما
السيناريوهات المحتمله في حال امتد الصراع
بين موسكو الى ساحات اخرى واي تاثيرات
لذلك على المشهدين الاقليمي والدولي
[موسيقى]
لم ينفي الجيش الاوكراني وكذلك فعل الجيش
السوداني وكلاهما معني بتحقيق لشبكه سي ان
ان الامريكيه اورد معطيات وخرائط ومشاهد
لما قال انها ادله تثبت شن قوات خاصه
اوكرانيه هجمات باستعمال طائرات مسيره على
قوات الدعم السريع في السودان المدعومه من
قبل قوه فاغنر الروسيه الشبكه اوردت في
تحقيقها المطول ان 6 غارات بطائرات من دون
طيار استهدفت في الثامن من الشهر الجاري
قافله من الشاحنات بين ام درمان والخرطوم
فيما استهدفت ثماني هجمات
مركبات ومبانيه ومسلحين داخل ام درمان حيث
توجد قوه الدعم السريع المدعومه من مجموعه
فاغنر الروسيه
ونقلت الشبكه عن مسؤول عسكري سوداني قوله
ان نحو 90% من اسلحه قوه الدعم السريه
تاتي من فاقنر
[موسيقى]
لمناقشه هذا الموضوع معنا من فريسه
الدكتور حسني عبيدي استاذ العلاقات
الدوليه بجامعه جنيف ومن ولايه مونتانا
مايكل
نائب مساعد وزير الدفاع الامريكي السابق
معك سيد مايكل سنبدا استنادا الى ما ورد
في هذا التحقيق
لسي ان ان كيف تتمكن القوات الاوكرانيه
القوات الخاصه الاوكرانيه من الوصول الى
السودان
وتنفيذ هجمات
بهذه الدقه ضد قوات الدعم السريع في ام
درمان وما بين ام درمان والخرطوم
نعم يسعدنا ان نكون معكم وتحياتي لضيفكم
الاخر ولذا انا عاده في مونتانا لكن اليوم
انا في واشنطن العاصفه العاصمه عفوا لكي
نتحدث تحديدا عن موضوع اوكرانيا فيما
يتعلق بتقرير لا ادري حقيقه هل هو مثبت ام
لا هل ان المسيرات هي من النوع الذي
تستخدمه القوات الخاصه الاوكرانيه ام لا
اذا ما ثبت ذلك فهذا يعني ان القوات
الخاصه
الاوكرانيه قررت ان تفصل بين وحدات فاغنر
وبين القوات التي تدعمها ايضا مره اخرى
اكرر لا استطيع ان اقول على وجه اليقين
لكن اذا حاولنا تحليل ما يفعلون هم لديهم
نزاع يشنونه داخل بلادهم واذا ما قاموا
بهذا العمل خارج
اراضيهم فهذا يعني ان لفاكنر دور وهي
تتلقى الدعم وتقدم الدعم لقوات اخرى
هذه المسيارات مداها هو 30 كيلومترا اذا
من قام بهذا الهجوم هذا يعني انهم قريبون
من المكان ولديهم جراه وشجاعه وايضا لديهم
كفاءه عاليه ان كانوا فعلا من الاوكرانيين
وهذا هو السؤال فعلا الذي طرحته يعني ان
كان ان كانوا فعلا من القوات الخاصه
الاوكرانيه كما يقول المصدر العسكري
الاوكراني كيف يمكن ان تكون هذه القوات
قريبه الى هذه الدرجه يعني ثلاثين كيلو
متر او حتى 15
كيلومتر من النقاط المستهدفه هل يمكن
الوصول من دون اي مساعده
ولو حتى داخليه سودانيه مثلا
مره اخرى هذا من قبيل التكهنات طبعا
انا اراقب العمليات الخاصه من فتره طويله
هي ليست سهله في التنفيذ خاصه اذا كانوا
هم لوحدهم من يقوم ذلكم سوف
ينكشفون امام الناس ليس من السودان ولا
يشبهون اهل السودان لذا من المتوقع انهم
تلقوا نوعا من المساعده
والعمليه بقربها الجغرافي
والمسيرات كما قلنا لم تمتلك مدى بعيد
لهذا السبب عليهما ان يكونوا قريبين من
موقعي الحدث وشن الهجوم سيد حسني عبيدي
طيب
لصالح من تكون هذه الضربات يعني لماذا او
ماذا تستفيد القوات الاوكرانيه الخاصه من
ضرب قوات الدعم السريع داخل السودان حتى
ولو كانت مدعومه ومموله من فاجنر ماذا
تستفيد ميدانيا القوات الخاصه الاوكرانيه
يعني اذا ثبت الخبر معنى ذلك ان القوات
الخاصه وخاصه الجهاز الاستخبارات
الاوكراني الذي كان قويا جدا وكان لديه
انتشار في العديد من المناطق خارج اوروبا
قبل الغزو الروسي معناها انه باستطاعه
اوكرانيا في النهايه
الحاق ضربات مهمه
بحكم ارتباطها الان الذي اصبح لم يعد سرا
مع القوات الروسيه مع وزاره الدفاع
والنقطه الثانيه تعلم جيدا بان السودان هي
منطقه تحرك تختلف على كل المناطق الاخرى
اعتبار انه هو في النهايه مصدر لمصدر
المهم يعني كل تقريبا مصانع الذهب
الموجوده في السودان تحت سيطره قوات
التدخل السريع وبالتالي يمكن فعلا اضعاف
هذه القدره قدره الانتاج وكذلك اضعاف
النقطه الثالثه هي هي القول كذلك
اعتقد الرساله موجهه لاكثر من يعني وانما
لموسكو بان في النهايه لاوكرانيا القدره
على تصدير وتوسيع رقعه الحرب الى مناطق
اخرى لاثبات انها يمكن الحاق كذلك ضربات
حتى بالمجهود الحرب الروسي نعم ولكن في
نقطه الحاق الضرر بيفاجنر ضرب قوات الدعم
السريع في اي يعني في اي اتجاه يمكن ان
يمثل ضربه لقوه فادنر
يمكن ان يكون ثنائيق تحرض فاقنار بالنسبه
السودان هي نقطه مهمه جدا يعني والتحالف
مع قوات التدخل السريع هو من يعني من احد
اساسيات اصلا عمل فاجنر اكثر بكثير من
المناطق اخرى خاصه في منطقه الساحل لان
التواجد فاقنا اصلا جاء بعد اتفاق ما بين
ما بين قوات التدخل السريع في قضيه
الاستفاده من معادن الذهب وكذلك في قضيه
الاستفاده ماليا واقتصاديا من من السودان
وكذلك ترغب يعني روسيا في النهايه ان تكون
هناك منطقه نفوذ لها مهمه جدا لكن في نفس
الوقت انا لا اعتقد بان في النهايه مصلحه
اوكرانيا ككل في ان تستمر هذه العمليه
يعني يعني تصدير العمليات العسكريه خارج
اوكرانيا في النهايه سيعيق المحتوى
الاخلاقي الذي الذي هو جوهر السرديه
الاوكرانيه قضيه التهديد تهديد اوكرانيا
من قوه اجن سيهدد كذلك السرديه حتى
الاجنبيه التي تساعد اوكرانيا وبالتالي
ستعطي ذريعه لروسيا في النهايه ان تقوم
بعمليات اخرى طيب سيد مايكل من من من هذه
النقطه تحديدا اود ان اسالك هل هذه الخطوه
تؤشر الى اتساع نطاق المواجهه لتشمل دولا
اخرى بين
اوكرانيا وروسيا
وربما تكون بين الغرب وروسيا ايضا
في حقيقه الامر كانت هذه هي قوات خاصه
اوكرانيه قامت بهذا العمل هذا يشير لي
بانهم بات يمتلكون الثقه بالنفس ليذهبوا
خارج بلادهم ويمتلكون الموارد خارج بلادهم
وفي اماكن لروسيا الكثير من التاثير
بصراحه طبعا قد يؤشر الامر اننا لقد نراهم
في مالي وفي ليبيا وفي جمهوريه افريقيا
الوسطى انا لا اعتقد انهم يملكون القدره
على ذلك مع كل ما يجري في بلادهم والقوات
الخاصه تلعب دورا جوهريا في الدفاع عن
البلاد وفي الهجوم المضاد
وفي ضرب مواقع لودوستين داخل الروسيه لا
ادري لكنه الايه حال يؤشر انهم يرون جدوى
في استهداف مجموعه
وايضا التي عاده تتعامل مع
ميليشيات انفصاليه لديها موارد ماليه ضخمه
سابقى معك السيد مايكل في هذه النقطه يعني
نقطه مهمه ذكرتها ان القوات الخاصه
الاوكرانيه غير قادره على ان توسع دائره
الصراع فاغنر موجوده في اكثر من منطقه في
افريقيا لماذا اختيار قوات سودانيه
متعاونه مع في السودان ولم تلجا هذه
القوات الى ضرب قوات فاجنر مثلا في دول
افريقيه موجوده
بالقوات موجوده فيها بشكل فعلي وقائم على
الارض لماذا اختيار قوات مدعومه من فاجنر
في السودان
انا لا ادري حقيقه هل هم شعروا بانه بان
تلك المركبات التي هاجموها كانت تحمل
افرادا من او كانت تابعه لقوات الدعم
السريعه التي تعمل
هذا كله من قبيل التكهنات اضافه التكهن
اصلا بان قوات خاصه اوكرانيا كانت
المسؤوله طبعا التقارير لا تؤكد ولا تنفي
وانا لا ادري ان كان الامر كذلك حقيقه لكن
هو مؤشر اضافه الى مؤشرات اخرى في المقال
نفسه يتحدث عن هجمات للمسيرات اذا كانت
فعلا قوات خاصه اوكرانيه ربما هم يريدون
استهداف قوه القوات هذه قوات الدعم السريع
لحيلوله دون استغلال روسيا لموارد السودان
الطبيعيه سيد حسني عبيدي عندما نتابع
التقرير الذي
نشرته السي ان ان
يظهر فيه وكان مسؤولين امريكيين
ابدوا اندهاشهم او دهشتهم من
من هذه الخطوه من هجمات قوات خاصه
اوكرانيه على قوات الدعم السريع في
السودان ولكن الى اي مدى يمكن ان تكون
خطوه من هذا النوع غير مغطاه غربيا
وامريكيا بالتحديد
من الصعب جدا تصديق روايه الاندهاش يعني
من الصعب جدا ان تكون هناك يعني عمليات
عسكريه صحيح هي ليست عمليات نوعيه كبيره
جدا اولا بحجم قبل كل شيء المسيرات ثم
كذلك السرعه وقدره هذه المسيرات على حمل
اسلحه فتاكه يعني هي في النهايه لم تقم
بعمليات عسكريه يمكن ان تغير مجرى الحرب
ثم انه من الصعب الوصول الى منطقه مثل
منطقه السودان دون علم الولايات المتحده
الامريكيه هذا لا يعني ان هناك ضوء اخضر
من الولايات المتحده الامريكيه لكن من
الصعب ان نصدق هذه هذه الروايه لكن الحذر
الاوكراني هو مؤشر يعني اعتقد مهم جدا لان
لانه اوكرانيا في حرجه ولا الرئيس
الاوكراني في حرج لانه من الصعب جدا القول
بان الجهد او الدعم المالي والدعم العسكري
الغربي وخاصه من اوروبا في النهايه جزء
منه يذهب الى عمليات عسكريه خارج يعني
خارج اوكرانيا خارج الدفاع عن اوكر وهو
المبدا الاساسي الذي قبلت به هذه الاموال
ويذهب في النهايه لعمليه عسكريه هي بموجب
قرار من داخل مجلس الامن ممنوعه يعني نذكر
بان هناك قرار مجلس الامن يعني يقوم بان
يقول بانه يجب ان يكون هناك حساب لعسكري
لاطراف النزاع في السودان اي عدم تصدير اي
سلاح وقانونيا المسيرات تعتبر او تدخل في
خانه الاسلحه وبالتالي هذا موقف محرج
بالاضافه كذلك الى موقف الدول الغربيه
الاخرى التي تقول في النهايه ان هذا يعني
انه من الممكن ان تتعرف الى نفس السؤال
لهجوم وفي النهايه تقول الدوله لكن هذا
يعيدنا الى نفس السؤال يعني حتى لو كان
محرجا للرئيس الينسكي او محرجا للدول
الغربيه لكن الامر حصل هل يمكن لهذا الامر
ان يكون من دون هذا الغطاء من دون التفهم
او الضوء الاخضر خصوصا انه يهدد كما ذكرت
انت
باتساع دائره المواجهه وبالتالي الغرب كله
معني بهذه المواجهه
انا في رايي لا يعني انا اعتقد ان هناك
علم بالولايات المتحده الامريكيه وحتى
لحلفاء الولايات المتحده لكن لنبدا
بالبدايه وهو ان هناك انزعاج كبير من قبل
الولايات المتحده وحتى الدول الغربيه التي
بدات الان العوده بقوه الى العديد من
الدول الافريقيه بسبب بسبب واحد وهو
التواجد القوي وكذلك النفوذ العسكري الذي
بدات تلعبه فاجنر فيمكن ان يكون هنا هناك
طلاق المصالح ما بين اوكرانيا وبين الدول
الغربيه التي تريد فعلا ان تحد او تحييد
التدخل والنفوذ
العسكريا بارسال هذه الرسائل التي ما زالت
انا اعتقد في مرحله في مرحله تمهيديه
لانها كما قلت لا تغير مجرى الحرب ولا
ميزان القوى داخل السودان طيب سيد مايكل
الى اي مدى يمكن اعتبار
هذه العمليه لو تاكد ت طبعا كما تكرر الى
اي مدى يمكن اعتبارها تهديد
غربي بتوسيع دائره المواجهه مع روسيا وان
على موسكو الحذر من انها لن تبقى معصوره
في اوكرانيا بل ستكون المواجهه في مناطق
نفوذها تحديدا في افريقيا
بالتاكيد انا ارى الاهتمام من منظوري
الحكومه الامريكيه في التصدي لعمليات
مجموعه
في افريقيا وهناك الكثير من الاموال
والاسلحه الروسيه تذهب الى هناك انا لا
ادري لكنني لا اعتقد او لا اعلم انهم
بصراحه
سيدعمون اي تحرك لاوكرانيا داخل افريقيا
علاوه على ما قلناه طبعا هم يحاولون الفصل
بين فاقنار ومن يدعمه من يدعمونه
ربما الامريكان يفضلون لو ان اوكرانيا
ركزت قوتها وقواتها الخاصه تحديدا ضمن
قدراتي دعمي الهجوم المضاد بدلا من ان
تهدر على هذا النوع من العمليات لكن اعتقد
ان بالتاكيد هذا الامر اثار اهتمام
الحكومه الامريكيه وان لم يعلم عنها من
قبل سيهتمون بالتعرف عليه الان هل تتوقع
من وجهه نظرك ان يكون هناك
اتساع
لدائره الصراع الى خارج اوكرانيا ويشمل
دولا اخرى غير السودان
اعتقد ان احد باعه القلق الكبير وهو ان
الله روسيا حققت نجاحا هذا لا يبدو كانه
كذلك لكن في بلدان مثلما بلدان مثل بولندا
وافرازات هذا النزاع قد تشمل بلدان مثل
بولندا على الاقل
والذي يعني ان النيتو سيدخل حربا مع روسيا
قد يكون هناك
تحول للحرب الى بلد اخر لكن ليس من جانب
اوكرانيا والغرب لكن من جانب روسيا ربما
اما استخدام المسيرات الصغيره من هذا
النوع لا اعتقد انها ستؤدي الى رحيل ليس
هذا بعث القلق لكن بعث القلق هو ان تدخل
روسيا في نساء مع بلد اخر
سيد حسني عبيدي مبعث القلق ان تدخل روسيا
في صراع مع بلد اخر هل هذا ممكن او
هل لموسكو مصلحه في ذلك بعنوان الرد على
الهجمات الاوكرانيه خارج الحدود
يعني هذه الفرضيه وارده لكن لا اعتقد انها
ستتحرى انها روسيا تتحرك يعني
في الاجل القريب اولا لانك كما اسلفنا
العمليات او عمليات القوات الخاصه
الاوكرانيه اذا ثبتت يعني ليست يعني
عمليات كبيره جدا تهدد وجود فاجنر لا في
السودان ولا كذلك في مناطق افريقيا ثم
نعتقد ان لابد من روسيا ان تتحقق قبل كل
شيء مصدر هذه العمليات العسكريه هو صحيح
لكن سيتفق مع ضيفك واشنطن بان مصدر الخوم
القلق من قبل روسيا التي يمكن ان تستعمل
هذه الورق ولذلك انا اعتقد انها هي ليست
في مصلحه اوكرانيا بالعكس هي هديه لروسيا
للقول في النهايه بان هناك توسيع رقعت على
الحرب وبان كذلك لروسيا لها على الحق في
الدفاع عن نفسها لكن الطرف الروسي والطرف
الاوكراني يحاولان دائما ان نائب بانفسهم
عن هذه العمليات العسكريه التي تقوم بها
في النهايه قواته اما قوات خاصه يمكن كمان
يقول بان هذه انها عمليه عسكري عسكريه ليس
لدينا القوه او لنقل التبعيه القانونيه
وكانها من قبل مجموعات مسلحه خارج اطار
القوات المسلحه حتى تتجد فرصه للخروج من
حيثيات القانون الدولي الانساني كما تقول
بالضبط روسيا نفس السرديه بان قوات فاجنر
هي قوات ليست رسميه وليست تابعه فنا اعتقد
فعلا بان الفرضيه من قبل موسكو هي وارده
جدا بتوسيع كذلك هذه العمليات وهذه مره
ستكون يعني اكثر وربما اخوف لانها ستكون
في منطقه قريبه جدا من الصراع اي من
اوكرانيا
منطقه قريبه من الصراع وفي في السودان
تحديدا السودان في قلب منطقه ايضا متوتره
اذا عدنا الى السودان وتاثير ذلك على
المشهد السوداني وعلى الواقع السوداني وما
يمكن ان يفرزه ايضا خارج حدود السودان اذا
ما كانت هناك تدخلات اقليميه اخرى اي
سيناريو يمكن ان يحصل حينئذ
الخوف بالنسبه في السودان هو دخول صحيحه
اطراف اخرى يعني باعتبار ان هناك دخول بين
هناك قوات اوكرانيه مع قوات التدخل السريع
عفوا ضد قوات تدخل السريع فهذه الاخيره
ربما ستجند دول اخرى
ضد مصلحه الولايات المتحده او ضد مصلحه
اوكرانيا تقول في النهايه بان الان المجال
مفتوح
ويمكن ان تقوم بمسانده قوات التدخل السريع
وبالتالي نخرج من هذا الصراع الذي كان الى
حد الساعه محدود بين طرفين صحيح هناك دول
اقليميه داعمه لكن ليس بطريقه رسميه وهذا
هو المنعطف منعطف المسيرات في السودان
وانه يمكن ان يوسع ليس فقط النزاع
الاوكراني الروسي وانما حتى كذلك النزاع
السوداني وبالتالي يعقد المشهد اكثر مما
هو معقد اليوم ويضعف من قوه البحث عن حل
سريعا سيد مايكل باختصار لا تست فيد
الولايات المتحده من اشغال روسيا في اكثر
من ساحه دوليه ولو عن طريق قوات فاجنر
نظري ارى ان هناك اهتماما في اللهجه
المتحده بان يتم احتواء مجموعه
ان لم يكن في كل الاماكن على الاقل في بعض
الاماكن التي ترى الولايات المتحده
انها قوه تكتيكيه تستغل الموارد الطبيعيه
لبلدان ناميه لاغراضها الخاصه
وايضا تضيف الى مستوى العنف الذي كان
موجودا حتى في حالات الحروب الاهليه ما
تريد المتحده تريد لهؤلاء ان يرحلوا
لكنهم لن يرحلوا وواضحوا انهم لن يرحلوا
لهذا السبب لو كانت هذه الهجمات تمت على
يد قوات خاصه اوكرانيه استطاعت ان تصل الى
هذه الاماكن شكرا
لك مايكل من واشنطن النائب مساعد وزير
الدفاع الامريكي السابق وشكرا للدكتور
حسني عبيدي استاذ العلاقات الدوليه بجامعه
كان معنا من باريس
شكرا لكم مشاهدينا على المتابعه والى
اللقاء
[موسيقى]